a hundred years ago Iceland lumbered
along is one of the poorest countries in
Europe
then during the Second World War it's
fishermen took great risks sailing
through minefields dodging warships and
submarines to feed the continent
riches poured in and the country
industrialized and modernized within a
couple of decades I've traveled to the
fishing village of grinned avec on the
country's southwest shore to see just
how far Iceland's fishing industry has
come boats arrive here every morning
packed full of cod and redfish and then
get transported to nearby processing
plates
inside one of these plants sits the most
advanced fish slicing gear on the planet
it's a machine made by the Icelandic
tech giant morale and it uses algorithms
to carve up the fillets that end up on
your plate we're gonna head into the
factory floor when they've got a couple
of the new morale machines it's people
and machines working side by side and
I'm sure it's gonna smell pretty foul I
prepped for the mechanized river of
death with good board
she's a mechanical engineer turned
operations guru who has spent the last
few months overseeing the installation
of these machines meet the flexi cut
first it x-rays the fish to spot bones
and then a water jet slices the fish
with great precision dozens of programs
run on the machine to slice the fish
just as customers want
if Tony Stark wanted to make fish tanks
this would be his machine
what's the key technology behind that
machine to be able to see the fillet and
cut it each time and every time the same
when you're doing the x-ray
what is the software doing yeah
calculating exactly how to cut because
you are throwing motifs on the water
jacks so we need to be very accurate
okay 50 fish per minute how quickly is
it making that decision we have less
than a second to take a picture estimate
and cut is everybody worried that the
machines are gonna come and take their
jobs yeah that is usually a warrior when
you have technology replacing manual
work we say we are actually creating
thanks a lot to come job is that
the reality is that humans will find it
tough to compete with these kinds of
machines perhaps with a bit of luck a
human touch will be required for the
fishy leftovers the morale hopes to
process next there's a lot to gain still
I think we haven't even started to
explore the value of byproducts of the
seafood